The joe rogan experience.
You don't,
you're not famous video of the guy that sets up his laptop and then records
maid's coming in while he's jacking off.
So like just explain the say that like we know,
oh I thought you know,
thing that you watch every day before you do anything.
There's this hilarious guy and you could find that [inaudible] dot com is one of
the websites that has it and it's just this guy that puts his laptop here and he
puts headphones on.
He just waits for the maid.
And then when she comes in he records like him jerking off and he has made her
as you're looking at a screen?
No,
he's just like,
you can't see his face.
You just see it's from his dick.
Oh my front door.
So like the maids come in one after another,
one after another and they're like,
they all do different things.
Most of them were like,
oh my God.
So sorry.
So I'm just sit there and just slowly turn around.
But his mission was to actually have somebody like fuck him or give him a blow
job.
He just released a second one where finally at the end,
I almost don't want to give it away.
I made does come up and just start staring at it and then slowly walks up and he
goes,
Oh,
do you want this?
And,
and he goes,
yes I do.
And the guys starts sucking him off on the video.
No,
it was a male.
I miss you.
I promise you the twist is that there's a male made.
No,
listen,
I don't know if you know this,
but I used to be on fear factor.
Right?
I know about reality TV.
I don't buy that.
I don't see that.
Please watch the videos watching guys talk.
You guys,
Dick,
I know what you're doing.
What you're doing is trying to trick you.
Try to convert us,
bro.
You know you don't know me as well as you think you know me.
I'm not that dumb.
Okay.
How dare you.
Well,
if trying to trick me into 500 other videos of women turning them down over and
over and over again and he,
I would not,
I would be on your boat to thicken.
It was fake.
But it's,
he's been doing this,
I've known it came out through [inaudible] is the one of the worst detectives in
the history of Scotland.
Yard help.
He's followed bad leads.
He said.
Yeah,
inspector Crusoe.
His first video came out like three to five years ago.
He's gotta be
your honor.
Yeah.
There's no need to further investigate it.
We've got this one locked up.
Don't pull it up.
Nobody wants to,
I don't want to watch God blow a guy.
I'm proud to say I was on one of these sites.
You have a day and yeah,
I don't know if anybody else does.
It's where you'll PDR periodically check in to make sure you're not gay.
I feel like 10 seconds of male porn and just go like,
nope,
still not good.
I'm still,
as of last week,
I'm still not good.
I think I'm out of the woods.
You don't want me to do it officially out of the woods.
Do you remember the old Kinison bit about that?
It was a,
he's like a
fantasy,
so I'm sitting around the house the other day.
Cause if there's one,
yeah,
I didn't like the idea of a guy.
There was,
I think it got,
was blown.
Another guy.
Stubble.
That's what Bob,
just like stubble
stubble anywhere near my precious.
Well,
men are crazy and they're violent and uh,
there are also that way if they're gay,
straight man,
crazy and violent and straight straight men and gay men.
They're,
the only difference is one of them likes boys.
Okay.
So the idea of that being hot and sexy,
uh,
a car,
it's like getting blown by crazy chimp and you know,
I don't trust dudes.
Some Studley muscular dude who suck on my Dick.
Exactly.
Just rip it off and throw it away and go,
ha ha.
I like how you went a little crazy on the ha.
Yeah.
A big muscular guy going,
hey
Harry.
Harry chess.
Perfectly Harry.
Not Too much.
It's trims it a lot to grow out a little,
but it doesn't get,
doesn't get unkempt.
Yeah,
they,
they're having a good time over there.
I gotta say the gays,
the gays have a weird life because if it wasn't for the persecution,
it's pretty God damn sweet.
If you think about it,
like if we all men and women,
okay.
And this is coming from a guy who has kids and loves having kids.
However,
there's a weirdness to having sex with men and women because it can possibly
result in a child.
That weirdness is eliminated with gay people.
It's just fucking,
and there's no Yang.
It's all Yin or Yang.
No Yen,
one of those,
whichever it is a hard one.
There's that.
Well,
there is a bit of a Yemeni,
there's,
there's a little bit of that as a bottom top issue,
but yeah,
but there's what the issue isn't what a man wants versus what a woman wants.
They're both men.
So the weirdness like the trying to figure out women,
especially like when you're young,
one of the weirdest things is just the idea of trying to think the way a woman
things you think the way a guy thinks,
you think everything's going to be fine.
And like I remember when I was young and I just started dating when I was like a
teenager.
I would talk to girls the way I would talk to my friends and they would get
upset and they would think you're crazy and can't do it.
You cannot change your language completely.
Change your language,
change your approach,
change the way you guys can fuck around with each other and we assume that we're
gonna like laugh and fuck around with each other back.
And that's what we did.
We insult each other halfass constantly.
You don't have that Irish fucking vengeance thing,
huh?
No,
I,
well if I did when I was young,
I eliminated it at all with thinking.
And you know that I've argued.
Do you argue with people in your head?
I don't allow myself to do an immune that anymore.
I used to do that.
I used to do that when I was a young man.
I used to,
if I was a young man,
I've got an argument,
someone,
I would relive that argument like every day for like 10 minutes for like a year.
Maybe I'll come back to it a year later.
It's fucking God,
I should have told that.
Fuck God.
Fuck you mister.
You have to like go through your notes.
Like what was I gonna say to him?
Oh yeah,
I was going to say that I used to talk about this on stage.
This is totally true.
When I was a,
I guess I was like 26,
I live,
I was living in Encino and I rented this house and it had an orange tree in the
front yard and I didn't pay my bills.
It's very irresponsible.
So this guy came over,
uh,
I turned the power back on and the guy came over to turn the power on and it
seemed like a nice guy said,
hey man,
uh,
those oranges a delicious,
if you want me to go grab one.
And he goes,
okay,
thanks.
So the guy took nine fucking oranges and I sat there watching them.
Like,
this mother fucker is taken more orange.
I can't believe this shit.
And to this day,
man,
I have to fight off the urge.
No,
no,
no.
It's not that story.
Three times.
It's real.
Like I was an asshole for,
to this day I'll be in my car and I'm driving down the street.
And I just go nine fucking oranges do.
Really?
That was 1993 did I tell you the story that the loan told me that I tell it on
this podcast?
No.
Shit.
Like this never happens.
Me and pivot one time flew to,
we're going to fight to a Mayweather fight and we get on the plane and fucking
Stallone is waiting.
Come on in.
Alright.
I guess we're going to a fight with Stallone.
Great thing about Stallone.
He knows what his good stories,
ours.
He,
you know what I mean?
He like knows what people want to hear about.
They want to hear about rocky.
They wanna hear about fucking,
they want to hear what,
so he's talking about he was directing the movie staying alive.
Oh,
uh,
yeah,
I remember that.
He was,
and it was a Travolta movie that,
that Frank Stallone's sang on the soundtrack.
That is correct.
Um,
so yes.
So Stallone said that he,
he goes,
he goes.
So I,
I called John Up to the house for a meeting about that song,
play that song while the story is going,
he goes alone.
This is the end.
I think it's called,
this is the end and staying alive soundtrack.
He goes,
he goes.
So John came up and he goes,
John's got a real food issue that people don't know.
And he goes,
he goes,
John comes up,
we're sitting at a table and he goes,
now,
my wife had made some homemade fudge that day.
So we sit at the table,
my wife puts out some fudge Travolta proceeds to eat the entire plate of food.
Oh yeah,
this fucking guy obey.
He goes,
which first of all,
his fucking route,
which is fucking made me laugh my head off.
And that was like that.
He hasn't forgotten that he,
that's his orange story is that,
is that,
um,
is that it was fucking rude.
That's still alone or that a turmoil.
Tate,
all of us.
Well,
he's hanging on to some shit from the early eighties right?
One was staying alive.
That was 82.
Remember when he's walking down the streets in New York City with a fucking fur
coat on and it got bumps into him.
Travolta bumps in on like Stallone,
you really remember this movie?
Now this is the wrong song.
Is that it?
Yeah.
What does it say?
It's call it far from over.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
This is a great spot.
Strong.
Okay.
Change.
Yeah.
This is it.
This is frank.
Stallone's stuff still owns brother.
This fucking song was the shit back in the day.
I wish I knew how to dance song.
I'm downloading this,
not even fucking around and say,
I forgot about this.
I wish I knew how to dance back then.
I want it to be a part of this world.
I wanted to be the impressive guy on the dance floor are spinning around and in
a perfect position.
It's still only said that they were shooting flashdance next door and he's like,
and we knew that that was going to be the one John Travolta met a single
handedly,
made more men gay just from this music and from singing and dancing and getting
people to dance.
He probably purse.
That was probably his total overall goal,
which is to say nothing of his bath house work just or the Shah's power work,
but just to be able to dance so good and make dancing fucking dancing.
It's not the Fred Astaire days.
This is a new era of manliness we get from you.
You were,
did you ever go to like a disco or,
yeah,
I did that of course.
So how would you want to get laid?
We went to just around with a sign.
Please fuck me and lay you fucking getting it out there now Brandon out there
and you did it,
dude.
I had caviar Ricci pants that they were tight on the top and they ballooned out
like Mc Hammer peasy.
It was all in my chest and I went on stage with those ones.
It's a disaster.
Look at him,
but he made dancing a manly thing that was attractive.
Okay.
This is one of the gayest things you could see a man do ever look at that.
Back that up for two seconds.
I want to show you what those guys are doing here on the hand job.
You know what they're doing.
Know they're doing.
They're pretending they're near a million dick here.
I'll play it.
This shit.
You suck at Youtube.
Now this youtube sucks.
Does it?
Well,
this is the,
uh,
the standard compilation that you had to have in those old school movies.
You to have this series of scenes where you see him failing,
failing,
and then practicing really hard on this dancing.
See,
he's waiting tables,
frustrated,
but when it gets out there,
back home
doesn't waiver me.
I got to use a phone.
I need the phone.
Everybody.
What is this
damn mud?
Yes.
You're going to get to be gay.
Come dance.
Yes,
I can dance.
Look at this,
those movement.
Look at that thing with the toes.
Whenever you point your toes like that,
you're begging for deck.
New.
Literal.
Yeah,
man.
You're pointing your toes.
A cry for help.
You're begging for it.
It's not in the wrong with Pega for deck.
Don't get me wrong.
Nothing wrong with being gay to,
to volt is a bad motherfucker.
See that?
See that you've got to be turned off for dark off.
Those are decks.
That's a hundred decks.
Hundred percent this is that.
It's just gimme a dik dik dik dik dik dik she be moving your fist towards your
face.
He trying to hit yourself in the face.
It's clearly not an outward move where the retraction is just bringing it back
to position.
Now they're pulling down.
That's pulling Dick's into your mouth.
Yeah.
I told him,
look,
I totally,
I saw it.
Nothing wrong with that to another testament to the,
to the gays are having a blast.
Yes.
They're having more fun for sure.
Sure works by kind of having a blast.
You know what?
The gays are not having fun.
The ones who fuck up and adopt kids,
they start thinking,
I'm going to be like a family.
We're going to get there.
We're going to get married.
We'd adopt kids.
And I'm like,
what does a lot of fucking work?
You realize they had the key.
They were,
they're winning the race and nobody had the baby out of their body.
Neither one of them.
So they're both standing there with this little motherfucker.
It's causing all sorts of problems.
Damn,
I fucked up the whole big gay party.
Is this another gate?
What are you doing here?
Okay.
She's,
she's acting.
She's talking about her baby.
Like you know how you were just saying the Dixon mouth.
This is a news reporter saying how she used to take her a electric toothbrush
and to help her kids gums,
but she did it on air and it just completely
keep the music plan.
[inaudible] let me get here.
That's two Dixie.
She's docking decks and then she's tasting them.
Gimme gimme gimme gimme gimme them.
Oh,
I'm going to sneeze when you dick.
It's delicious.
Yeah.
It's funny that you're not supposed to ever think of those people being sexual.
Like if she actually did do that and start it with like,
like,
oh yeah,
I fucking believe this car,
a home loan.
I think that's the fun,
one of the fun parts about having sex with women is how different it is from
what they're normally like.
Cause you and I are eight or 10 seconds.
I can imagine you fucking within eight seconds of right now someone wants to
fuck and he's really close to me.
I know what you're doing.
Girls got fucking jewelry on and her decorum.
I see what you're saying,
like,
and then the difference between like a girl and real life and a girl getting
fucked or fucking is so fast and it's so awesome and so exciting.
You mean talking dirty and they want some dinner fucking sweating and they
fucking legs or splits the best picture near Predator fucking now.
Yeah.
I can't help it.
You're so clever.
I see what you've done.
Both of you together should,
he should get together and try.
Please got together a video.
You should really check out.
Joe.
I'm going to get you to think about a guy sucking a guy's Dick and I'm gonna get
you to watch it.
And then you're like,
I want you to think about me having sex,
so I see what you both have done.
How dare you?
How dare bolt.
Some comic was telling me that when he'd go on the road,
him and his buddies who were staying at the hotel together,
they knew that they were going to try to bring girls back to the hotel room
afterward.
Uh,
and they wanted the girls to not be wearing a lot of close,
so they would turn the heat up as high as they could and the hotel.
How weird is that?
How dumb does that all make?
Girls are in a hotel room.
They'll get Nicky.
Next thing I know we're fucking,
because you know how that goes.
Yeah.
When people get really hot and lethargic,
that's when they're the best investment they want.
It can't stop thinking about when you're about to dehydrate you about the
blackout,
that's when you really want to throw down.
Yeah.
Just to bring a lot of water.
Give them water and they'll fuck you.
Are you add and Ami right now?
Checking on right there.
I want to check in saying that's what I'm saying.
Don't do that.
Put that fucking phone man.
You can interrupt.
Donate it.
The flow of the conversation is interrupted.
If you left those fucks in your mind.
Thought you were.
I felt like the flow.
I felt like you were putting a dam up a damn.
I thought you were fucking beavering.
You don't want to think about you fucking or I don't want this one did walk.
The work flow was going,
Joe wasn't,
I got news for you.
That's where it was headed.
It was there already going there.
It was already there.
Hmm.
Brian's got videos of bears making out for no reason.
Yeah.
Okay.